[MUSIC PLAYING]
RANDY DYER: Well,
good afternoon.
Thanks for joining
us at this session
and taking some time out
of this awesome conference.
So my name is Randy Dyer.
I've been with LL
Bean for 35 years.
And during that
time, I've really
been privileged to have worked
on our front-end systems,
in the architecture and
design of those systems,
including llbean.com and
our call center systems.
CHRIS CUMMINGS: Hi, there.
I'm Chris Cummings.
I have been working in the
retail industry, for many years
and in online retail
direct-to-consumer commerce
for the last couple of decades.
About five years ago, I
started a company named
Fearless Technology Group.
We're a consulting firm focused
on helping customers modernize
their technology architectures.
And we've been
working with LL Bean
since the start of the
modernization journey
that we're going to share
with you here today.
I just wanted to say thank you
for coming out here to hear us.
We're the last
session of the day.
I know we're between
you and happy hour,
and I know those seats
are really comfortable.
So hopefully, you guys,
we'll be somewhat interesting
and keep you awake
here, but thank you.
RANDY DYER: So we're
going to tell you
a little bit about our
monetization journey.
We're going to talk some about
the evolution of LL Bean,
so you can see where we
were coming from here.
We're going to talk
about our case for change
and then our vision
for the future.
And then we're going to talk
about how we're actually
realizing that vision.
We'll talk about
some of the lessons
we've learned along the way.
And then we'll talk a
little bit about the journey
forward from here.
So if you don't know
LL Bean, LL Bean
is a company that sells apparel
and equipment for, well,
either casual wear or outdoors.
You might have seen our boots
or have a pair of our boots.
And our catalogs
have been around
in the mail for a long time.
LL Bean is a
family-owned company.
It's been in
business since 1912,
when we started out
as a catalog company.
LL Bean is passionate
about getting people
into the outdoors.
And our brand strategy
is really about providing
products and
experiences that are
made for the sheer
joy of the outdoors.
Recently, we just launched
our Be an Outsider campaign.
You might have seen that.
And that's really about
getting families outside.
And family is whatever
you consider your family.
It might be your kids,
your pets, or whatever.
And then also we've
extended that-- you
may have seen a little bit
of that-- into the workplace,
with our Be an Outsider at
Work, where we partnered
with Industrious to deliver
some outside work spaces
in and around different cities.
So like I mentioned, LL Bean
started out as a catalog
company back in 1912.
And catalog is what really drove
our business for the first part
of the 20th century.
In 1996, we launched
our e-commerce website.
It was pretty early
on in that era.
And today, our
e-commerce website
actually accounts for more
than 2/3 of our revenue.
Other than the catalog,
up until the early 2000s,
we really had just
one retail store
located in Freeport,
Maine, where
the company headquarters are.
And in early 2000s
or so, we started
to expand our retail
presence a bit.
And today, we've got over 50
stores around the country,
and kiosks and some other
mobile stores as well.
As we kind of went
through the change
on how we were delivering
capabilities to our customers
and doing business, each
channel sort of kind of
grew up on its own.
So we had systems to really
support that direct marketing
and catalog and, you
know, phone order entries
and those kinds of things.
When we launched the
website, we had a website
that had a lot of
the capabilities
for taking orders over the web.
And then store sales.
Part of the issue is
that as time's gone on
and customers have
started experiencing us
across these different
channels, their interactions
are changing as well.
They want to do things and
interact with LL Bean in all
of those different channels.
And they want to
do it seamlessly.
And part of the problem was
is that our systems had really
kind of reached the point where
they just couldn't support
those evolving customer needs.
CHRIS CUMMINGS: OK,
we're going to get
to the what we did here soon.
But one thing first is just
to highlight that this is not
a unique to LL Bean trend.
It's not even a unique
to retail trend.
There are customers across
all kinds of verticals
are changing their behavior.
They have different
expectations of brands.
And there's all kinds
of metrics out there
in the industry
to reference that.
We pulled three of
them up here to share.
The first one, "Harvard Business
Review" says 73% of consumers
now use multiple channels when
making a purchase from a brand.
And 87% of the
customers surveyed
think that brands
need to invest more
in making those
experiences across channels
more consistent.
So they're clearly saying
something to the brands
these days that
they're not happy.
The experiences
are not consistent.
They want the same
company no matter
whether they're
interacting with them
on a web channel, on
their phone, in the store.
And they don't want to start
a transaction in one channel
and then start from
scratch in another.
So expectations have been
raised for the brands.
Investment is required.
But the good news is that
there is ROI available.
Last metric is 30%
higher lifetime value
for customers interacting
through multiple channels
versus those who only engage
through a single channel.
And though the bar
has been raised,
the brands are stepping up.
They need to step up
and meet this challenge.
And frankly, the way we've
all been building systems
for the last two decades
is no longer good enough
to meet that challenge.
Something clearly has to change.
RANDY DYER: So about
three years ago,
we were approached
and asked if we
could look at how we can
simplify the interactions
with our customers.
So one of the things
that we did is just
took a step back
and looked at all
of those different
interactions and saw
that things like
a customer might
come into a store with an item
that they purchased online,
and they want to
return it, and they
want to replace it with another
item that maybe doesn't exist
in the store.
So that order is going
to be placed in the store
and shipped from the online
channel, as an example.
So in looking at all of
those different interactions,
we started to then step back and
say, what are the inhibitors?
What's kind of keeping us
from delivering those cleaner
customer experiences?
As I mentioned
earlier, our systems
were a core part of
some of those barriers.
Not that they didn't
have great capabilities,
because in their own channels
and in their own right,
they do.
But they just weren't
designed to work
with each other for these
new kind of interactions.
So we stepped back and looked
at our application architecture
to really understand
what was going on.
And some of the things that
we found are somewhat obvious.
The applications were siloed.
But what that means
it made it difficult
for us to provide a common
customer experience there.
Those applications
were monolithic.
Some of them are getting
long in the tooth.
Some of them have been in
place for 20 years or so.
They were implemented
back in the days when
we did monolithic systems
and tightly coupled and all
of that kind of thing.
So ultimately that just
makes those applications
costly and
challenging to change.
A small change in one
of these applications
requires that we go through
and do all kinds of regression
testing to make
sure that we haven't
broken things unintentionally.
And that's manually intensive.
All of these applications
are delivered
through on-premise
infrastructure.
And not that that's a bad thing,
but in some ways it's limiting.
We don't have a lot of
flexibility or ability
to deliver new infrastructure
and capabilities rapidly.
And then, you know, with a
seasonal business like ours,
as you might imagine, during the
holidays, we get really busy.
A lot of the rest of the
year, we're much less busy.
But we have to plan for
that capacity all year long.
So we took a step back and tried
to come up with or understand
what we needed to
change in order
to solve some of these issues.
We came up with what we
described, what we called,
our omnichannel architecture.
And this architecture
really was designed
to meet the goals of supporting
these consistent customer
experiences.
We also needed it to improve
our agility and our speed
to market, getting new
capabilities out there.
And we needed it to be built
on a modern architecture.
I've been around this
merry-go-round enough times
that this will probably
be about the third time
that we've re-imagined
and re-envisioned
these applications to
serve our customers.
And so we're just sort of
planning for that next cycle
to make sure it can
live that life cycle.
So the vision that we created--
what we found that
we needed to do
is we had sort of envisioned a
lot of different capabilities
around microservices
and cloud platforms
and all of this kind of thing.
But when you want to sell
that to an executive,
you got to simplify it.
And so what we did is created
sort of this one-page vision
document that described what
it is that we wanted to do.
And I'm not going to go into
a lot of details on this.
But the idea here was that
this isn't the system design.
This is really a tool
just for communicating
with those executives.
And what we found is that
having something like this
was really important,
because every time we went
into a meeting with those
executives, you know,
we they're busy.
They got a lot on their minds.
And we had to kind
of refresh them
on what it is we're
talking about,
why are we talking about
it, and that kind of thing.
And so having
something like this
was really valuable
for doing them.
It was also eye opening in
that, obviously, executives
sort of know what
we do as a business.
But when you start to put all
of the pieces kind of in front
of them, then it starts
to open their eyes
up a little bit about just all
of the complexity that's there.
When you do something
like this, one
of the things you want
to do is use a little bit
of artistic license.
And so for example, just
as you look at the picture,
you can see that the systems
on the bottom, the enterprise
applications, don't
really compare
in scale to what's on the top.
Those are obviously
large, important critical
applications, but
they're not the focus
of what we're targeting.
So they're just kind of a
little less in scale there.
So anyway, the point of
this is create a vision.
Make it simple.
Put it on one page.
What we found after
doing this as well
is that other teams
started using this document
in their presentations and
in their selling of what
they wanted to do.
So they could sort of
latch onto the success
that we were having
here with our momentum.
So I just kind of boiled down
that document a little bit
so that we could talk
a little bit more
about how Google Cloud
fits into all of this.
So at the top of the
diagram, we had our customer.
We have our customer
interaction applications.
And that could be our
point of sale system
or a customer-facing website
or mobile web, custom store
applications,
contact center, etc.
All of those applications
in our vision
and what we're working toward
is that those applications
share capabilities through
shared services, which
are exposed as APIs.
And those shared services
could either be custom built.
They could be purchased.
Or they could be legacy, like
in the case of our commerce
system.
To date, we've
actually been working
on several parts of this.
We have several pieces
in production today.
So as an example, our
customer-facing website,
the UI layer of our
customer facing website,
many of the pages that you see
if you go to our website today
are actually delivered
with this architecture.
Some core services, like
our purchase history,
inventory availability
service, are delivered
as custom services today.
And we are in the process
of implementing a promotion
service that we actually
purchased as we speak.
All of this is tied together
through an API gateway.
We are using Apigee as
our API gateway today.
We've actually been using
Apigee for probably three
plus years at this point.
So we actually had a pretty good
base of APIs already in Apigee.
And then just to sort of
where does Google Cloud fit
into this?
That customer facing
UI, like you mentioned,
runs on GCP and GKE.
Those custom services
also run in GKE.
And that purchase
service will run in GKE.
We've got some on-prem
services that are not in GKE.
They're really part of our
legacy commerce application.
But we are leveraging those.
And we've layered an API
layer on top of that.
CHRIS CUMMINGS: So you've seen
where we started at LL Bean
and you've seen where
we're trying to go.
How we're trying to realize
this vision, what it looks like.
So how did we come to use
Google Cloud Platform?
Let's talk about that.
It's a Google conference.
And we chose GCP about
a year and a half ago.
We didn't really
start there, though.
The first thing we embraced
pretty strongly on this journey
to realize the vision
was Kubernetes and really
first and foremost containers.
But then as we
looked for a place
to operate those containers,
deploy, run them,
we embraced Kubernetes.
And we went after
the containers early
because we just saw the
benefits, the immutability
of those environments, the
ability to spin up environments
rapidly during the dev
cycle, scale horizontally
very easily if the
app's designed for it.
It was just very compelling.
So we embraced
containers, Kubernetes.
That led us a bit naturally
to Google Cloud Platform.
At that time there was
really not another game
in town from the big providers.
They were starting to
talk about Kubernetes
and they weren't embracing it.
That has changed in a big way.
Everybody is
scrambling to catch up.
But Google, still pretty
much the leader here.
But that wasn't the only thing.
Kubernetes is a great example
of Google's open source
commitment.
And we're benefiting
from that with a number
of other applications
that we use.
And we just really liked
that open source commitment.
We like their whole
approach to it.
We didn't see quite
the same stance
with the other providers.
Security architecture.
There were some things about
Google's security architecture
that we thought were very
appropriate for a cloud native
environment.
That zero trust
approach was different
than traditional on-premise
approaches that were being used
at the time we encountered it.
But we could see the power.
We embraced it.
And we've kind of blended what
Google brings to the table
there along with some security
capabilities that are there
with container,
containerized apps.
There are some things you can do
that are kind of new and unique
in some ways.
And then we've blended a
few on-premise measures
into the mix for a pretty
healthy blend on the security
front.
A few other things
to hit quickly here--
dynamic scale.
Randy mentioned the seasonality.
That's a big win for a
retailer, not surprising.
Cloud native brings the ability
to position teams to innovate.
A lot of that's by the
speed at which they
can move to market,
the speed of which they
can try new technologies.
We really felt like we had the
tools necessary with Google
in that area.
And then finally,
being a retailer
with digital marketing, there's
a key business relationship
with LL Bean and Google that
we felt was an advantage.
With Cloud native in
general, with some things
with Google in particular,
we like the pricing model.
So what does our deployment
look like on GCP?
Well, I'm going to go yet more
simple here and just highlight
three major components
that make up
the core of what we are doing.
Google Cloud native, GCP, GKE
is obviously a key part of that.
But over the top
of that, we've laid
a microservices
architecture down.
And we really
embraced microservices
earliest in the game here.
And we really embraced
the principles
behind microservices, the
domain-driven design concepts
that are there, the
separation of concerns,
the loosely coupled
applications,
bounded context, language having
meaning within those contexts.
And we also embrace
the idea that teams
could align with application
domains, business domains.
And when you mix all that into
a microservices environment
deployed the right
way, it really
allows you to move
all the pieces forward
at their own pace.
It really, really changed
the game for LL Bean.
At the time,
microservices weren't
as widely adopted outside of
the big internet companies.
It's become much more
industry standard now
and much more accepted.
Also, here, dev ops pipeline
is a key part of the puzzle.
Continuous integration
and delivery,
that's how everything
gets built,
tested, stress tested,
vulnerabilities
scanned, deployed, monitored,
maintained, all of that.
There is a strong
pipeline here that
is a key part of
everything that goes out
onto the platform and
a key part of what
we consider our platform.
So this looks really simple.
Is it really that simple?
No, it's really not that simple.
There's actually a
lot more going on
than that simple picture shows.
There is a healthy mix
of things that Google
provides as a service.
But there's also
a bunch of stuff
that we've brought to the table.
And really, the
point of this slide
is not to talk about
each one of these things,
but to highlight that,
the Cloud native approach
we chose allows us a lot of
flexibility to mix the bits
and pieces together that we
feel are right for a given job.
And examples are GCP, the
backbone GCP itself, Compute
Engine, Kubernetes Engine,
things like Pub/Sub for event
messaging, Cloud
Spanner as a service,
relational database that we
use for inventory availability
and some other things.
All great stuff we get
as managed services.
But on the stuff
we've rolled, we
have key dev components,
dev pipeline stuff,
GitHub, Jenkins, CI,
Nexus Artifact Repository.
We use Terraform for
infrastructure automation.
And then just as an
example, MongoDB,
we chose just to go with MongoDB
for some reasons that were
very specific to our use case.
But we were able to deploy that
as a service for our dev teams.
So from a dev team standpoint,
they need a relational DB.
They've got an option with
Spanner and with other things.
But with a document
store DB, they've
got an option with Mongo,
and they don't have
to go build that themselves.
They can use it.
So powerful mix going
with Cloud native
and putting the pieces out
there to enable the dev teams.
But how do we do
all that at LL Bean?
Well, one of the things that
we did early in the process
is we established what we
call a platform services team.
And this team has a mission.
The mission is to maintain
the systems and processes
necessary for agile and
continuous software delivery
and furthermore to enable
the dev teams to embrace
DevOps culture and practice.
So these guys aren't
the development team.
These guys are the platform
team who maintains the platform,
stewards it forward, takes
care of security concerns,
manages and maintains
that DevOps pipeline,
and a myriad of other things.
They collaborate heavily
with the dev teams.
Our dev teams build software
applications using all of this,
and they deploy them.
Just a few practice
areas to highlight.
And their mantra--
and those of you
who have read "The Continuous
Delivery Book" and "The DevOps
Handbook," you see some things
that probably look familiar
here.
But automate
everything, if you're
doing microservices of scale.
If you're going cloud
native, you can't really
have manual steps in all this
if you're going to be efficient.
It just doesn't work.
But they do things like
infrastructure automation,
scripting this stuff to create
the systems and configs that
are necessary, letting
teams spin environments
really quickly and easily.
Everything to do with continuous
delivery is in their domain.
And then site reliability
engineering, you know,
we want to push out fast.
We also wanted to be stable,
get immediate feedback,
react to that and
make sure we've
got healthy systems go forward.
So a big lesson learned--
we'll share a few more lessons
learned here in a few slides--
but strongly recommend
you consider,
if you've got some magnitude
in your environment, a platform
services team to
help you forward.
RANDY DYER: Great,
so before I move on,
one thing I wanted to add to
what Chris was just saying
is on that list, which I won't
flip back to, but on that list
you might have seen Cloud
Spanner on there for example.
And Cloud Spanner
in some ways might
be a bit overkill for what
we're using it for today.
We've got some other
use cases where
it will be more effective.
But one of the
things about that is
that I want my teams to be
focused on the customer,
delivering customer value.
I don't want my team to have
to become technology experts
and learn how to do
things like stand up
database environments
that are highly available
and all of that kind of stuff.
There are technology
providers that
can do that much
better than we can
and much more
efficiently than we can.
And that's why we want to
leverage that kind of thing.
So I just wanted
to call that out.
One of the things I'm
going to talk about
is one of the examples
of applications
that we've delivered,
and I've already
mentioned it, that's the LL
Bean website, or at least the UI
layer of that
llbean.com website.
And the reason I want to
talk about is because--
I'm going to talk a little bit
about how this platform has
really given us some
capabilities that we
didn't have before there.
So in order to
really explain this,
I got to talk a little bit
about how our legacy website was
built and architected.
We first implemented it back
in 1996, like I mentioned.
It underwent a big
technology change in 2001
when we switched it over to the
WebSphere Commerce platform,
all based on Java
and JEE and all
of those kinds of technologies.
The UI layer at
the time was really
part of that monolith,
implemented in JSPs.
And as time goes by, the
site became more dynamic.
We started layering
on lots of JavaScript
to make everything
dynamic and robust.
And then as new devices
started to become prominent,
then we added more JavaScript
to handle those kinds of things.
So anyway, it got to the point
where that UI application was
just very complex and fragile
and difficult to maintain
and all of that.
So that was another thing.
So we said we got to
step back and figure out
a better way to do this.
So we came up with what
we called just simply
the front-end architecture.
And what front-end
architecture is
is a framework that
we put together,
based primarily on React and
other open source libraries,
all based in node JS.
And this architecture allows
us to deliver customer facing
applications that will run
on either desktop, mobile,
or tablets, any
form factors there.
And like I mentioned, we are
using it to replace that UI
layer on llbean.com today.
And we have plans to use
it for other capabilities
as well, like in
our call centers.
Not only is it using React,
but the architecture also
defines how we use React.
So it employs an
atomic design model
that really mandates that
all the other components are
loosely coupled
and independently
developable and deployable.
And obviously, it supports
responsive web design
and accessibility
requirements out of the box.
And we've found that
since we've implemented,
it's actually been a pretty
good improvement in performance
and gives us some scalability
and speed to market with this.
And it just is a
platform that gives us
the ability to support ongoing
experience optimization.
So I mentioned that we
have gone to production
with many of the
pages on our website
under this architecture.
And that deployment obviously
is on Google Cloud Platform
or in Google Kubernetes engine.
So what the value
of the platform
brought to all of
this, though, is
that, other than the scaling and
things I mentioned, is that--
so a little case study here.
A few weeks ago, we
implemented a new version
of this application
that included capability
around the category pages.
And shortly after
we were deployed,
we started getting some
alerts from the monitoring
that we had set up.
And those alerts were
telling us that Kubernetes
was doing lots of pod restarts.
And so when we
looked into it, it
was doing the pod
restarts because we
had seen that the
memory usage started
climbing pretty rapidly.
And Kubernetes, we'd set it
up with some thresholds that
says, when you get to a
certain point in memory usage
restart itself so
that everything
stays clean and running.
And so that's what it was doing.
So because it was doing
that, customers never
saw that we were having
an issue and never
had any downtime or
anything like that.
I point this out because if this
were our legacy website that
doesn't have these
capabilities-- it doesn't have
something like Kubernetes
doing this kind of management--
then it probably
would have keeled over
and twitched its
feet for a while.
But that didn't
happen in this case.
The other part about this,
like Chris mentioned,
we've got the CI/CD
pipeline in place
that allows us to
do rapid deployments
and frequent deployments.
So as part of the problem
resolution to all of this,
we were able to get in,
analyze what was going on,
make changes, and get it
into production quickly.
It turned out that the problem
was actually a little deeper
than what we thought.
So the first implementation
didn't solve the problem.
But because, again, the rapid
ability to turn things around,
we were able to get the issue
solved in about four hours.
On our legacy
site, that probably
would have been at least
a day and an overnight
in order to solve something like
that and likely, very likely,
would have been an
outage to the website.
So that's just an example
of some of the advantages
that we've seen on
the platform so far.
CHRIS CUMMINGS: OK, so I
mentioned some learnings
we were going to share.
And we picked five things to
raise up and highlight here.
In reality, we are
practicing agile here.
So we are doing iterations,
retros, continuously learning,
and trying to improve.
But when you step back and you
look at the big picture of what
we were doing, these stood out.
And we thought they would
be worth sharing with you.
Couple of them you've already
heard something about.
Number one, establish that
vision for the future.
You saw what the one
for LL Bean looked like.
Yours will look different.
But it's really important
that you do that upfront
and you do it in a way that
everyone in the organization
who needs to can embrace it.
So the IT on the ground
folks, the developers
have to be able to understand
that the IT management has
to get on board.
But those executives
have to understand
at the right level what this
is that we're trying to do.
And the reason
that's important is
because this is not a project.
This is a journey.
So if you have an
organization of any magnitude
that you're trying
to do this in,
it's going to be a
multi-year commitment.
And that multi-year
commitment is
going to have to have
executive sponsorship.
It's going to have
to have budget.
There's no way you can
get there without selling
that this is a
journey worth taking
and that vision is
critical to do that.
It's OK to start with
prototype projects
and such at the outset.
We did that.
But really, you can't think
about it as a project.
Don't do that.
But do iterate.
You can do this by iterating,
by bringing business value
along the way, by learning
and changing course as you go.
But it's going to take time.
Third one, embrace DevOps
is what we summed it up as.
But what it really means
is to get the ROI out
of a big modernization
effort, you
have to recognize it's more
than just the technology.
It's the people and the process.
You won't get the
benefit if you keep
trying to build software
the way you've always
built it, if you're not
willing to reorganize where
appropriate, to align
teams with product domains,
allow them some
independence, and evolving
those and deploying them, let
them fail fast and recover.
It's a different way of
thinking for a lot of companies.
And it's frankly way harder
than the technology here.
We kind of challenged
pretty much everything
that LL Bean was doing
with software development
when we went when
we went after this.
But it's worth doing.
Fourth thing I've
already talked about.
Establish a platform
services team.
Especially if you're
going cloud native,
especially if you have more
than a few development teams,
it will pay off.
And then finally, engage
security at the outset.
We hear this all the time.
People are always telling us
get security on board up front.
We did this.
And in hindsight, if we had
waited six months, 12 months,
18 months down the road and then
tried to retrofit security in,
it would not have
been a good outcome.
It would have been very
costly and painful.
It would have disrupted
development tracks.
And it's pretty
likely it would not
have been as good an
outcome as we have now.
But we did this upfront.
And the way we did
that-- twofold.
One, we established an executive
sponsorship team, a steering
committee, if you
will, at LL Bean.
Key business execs who had a
stake in what we were doing
and the right IT management
resources, the head of security
was on that committee.
And so he was
there at the outset
as we started talking
about going to the cloud,
going cloud native.
When we established
a platform team,
we added a security
architect to that team.
So that individual was
there right up front.
And it's paid off.
We really had no idea
where the security path was
going to lead when we started.
And we found our way through,
and we continue to evolve.
But we found it to a good place.
So just a few lessons there.
There are probably hundreds
or thousands of micro lessons
you come across as you
do something like this.
Five that we thought were
worth mentioning to you.
RANDY DYER: Great.
So where are we going from here?
So we mentioned we actually
started this effort
a couple of years ago.
At the time, GKE was
pretty early in the market.
And I don't remember exactly
which version we started on,
maybe 1.4 or
something like that.
So we had to do a lot of
work to secure things,
to get things interconnected
the way they needed to be
with what we had at the time.
Obviously, since
then, things like SDO
are coming on board that can
solve a lot of the problems
that we had to kind of
work around at the time.
So part of this journey
is to continually
evolve that platform
as new capabilities
come in, as things
change, and to continue
to build out that layer of
services that you saw earlier.
So we've got active
development underway
right now with some
new capabilities
that we'll be rolling
out probably--
we'll actually
complete development
before our peak
season, but we actually
won't roll them out until
after, just because we
don't want to do that.
And then the other
thing that we are doing
is many of the legacy
systems that we're
replacing at this point, like
I mentioned, are fairly old.
Some of them are
very batch oriented.
And so as we're going
through this re-architecting,
we're really looking
at these from more
of an event-based approach.
And so part of the
work that we're doing
is starting to layer some
event processing capabilities
onto the platform.
And then the other thing
that we've got going on
is, as a direct marketer,
as you might expect,
we've got a lot of data, a lot
of data about our customers
and how they interact with us.
And we use that data
to model for delivering
catalogs and emails and all
of those kinds of things.
So there's a lot of
analysis that we do.
And up until this
point, we've done
that really with your
traditional enterprise data
warehouse capabilities
and tools like SAS
and some of these other things.
But again, as things
like the targeted ads
and all of that
kind of thing just
have created more and more
data that we need to process,
and so our current
infrastructure is just running
out of steam doing that.
So we've got some
work underway where
we are pulling a
lot of that data
into the Google Cloud
Platform and using tools
like BigQuery and Cloud--
sorry-- Dataflow.
With all these tools, I can't
keep track of all of them.
So that work is underway.
And like Chris
mentioned, we've got
a roadmap for all of this
work that we've created.
And we expect to be
continuing on this roadmap
for at least the next few
years, as we bring all of this
together.
So we hope we've given you some
information and some insights
into our journey.
And hopefully they can help you.
So thank you.
And so before we leave, I
just want to invite all of you
to also become an outsider,
enjoy the outdoors,
and you can find us at
llbean.com up there.
We are here for questions if
anybody wants to ask questions.
We're also here
at the conference
if anybody's interested in
chatting in more detail.
We're certainly
willing to do that.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS CUMMINGS: I guess
if anybody has a question,
I actually don't
see a microphone.
So you can just shout it.
We're pretty close.
Oh, I see it.
There it is up there.
AUDIENCE: Hey, guys.
Thanks very much for
the presentation.
Could I just ask you maybe a
little left field question?
Did you ever consider
before starting this journey
to use something commercial,
off the shelf, Commerce Cloud,
Iberus, something like
this, before you went down
this journey of creating
the developments?
RANDY DYER: Yeah, in
fact, our current website
is on a commercial
product, so to speak.
It's on WebSphere Commerce.
So we absolutely
did consider that.
One of the things that we, in
our current implementation,
our website is relatively
rich in capabilities.
And we wanted to keep that.
In our current
implementation, we
had to do a lot of customization
in order to get there.
And that was just
kind of a model
that we didn't really want to
go down at this point in time.
The other thing is, again, we've
got a pretty big presence still
in the call centers.
So we get a lot of orders
coming in over the phone.
And so we really wanted
to be able to blend
those channels together.
And that was
something that we just
didn't see really happening well
in sort of those products that
were really targeted either for
digital commerce or whatever.
CHRIS CUMMINGS: I would
add one thing to that.
And that is just LL Bean
is a pretty sophisticated
digital marketer
in a lot of ways.
And I think there was a desire
to have some best of breed
capabilities in a number of
different areas versus kind
of get inside someone's platform
and just live within there.
And I don't know, I've seen
those in multiple places.
Sometimes they've worked well.
A lot of times, the dream
doesn't come together
by getting this all
from one vendor.
But that was at play as well.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I hope you understand, my
voice is a little bit--
but thank you very much.
As you explained, you
did a really big change
in your company.
Who was initializing this?
Was this a technical part or
was it done by management?
CHRIS CUMMINGS: Who
here sponsored it?
RANDY DYER: So I
would say it was both.
The original thoughts
around our changing customer
base and those kind of
things and, oh, by the way,
we're not really
servicing them very well,
is something that our leadership
had recognized a while ago.
And so that's kind
of how it started.
From there, we kind of took
it and said, all right,
what sort of the things that
are holding us back there?
And what do we need to do?
So that's kind of
when it kind of became
that blend of more business
and technology kinds of things.
Our sponsor really when
we started this off
was the senior vice
president of marketing.
And he was kind of
our initial support.
From there, though,
we quickly were
able to get the support of the
CIO and the chief marketing
officer and all of
really the c-suite there.
And
CHRIS CUMMINGS: It
was that one-pager.
Honestly, it was
that one page that
brought everybody together.
It was pretty kind of
mind boggling to me
that that did what it did.
But it was worth about a
billion words in this case.
RANDY DYER: Nothing else?
Happy hour.
All right.
CHRIS CUMMINGS:
Thanks, everybody.
RANDY DYER: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]